so I got four kids eleven nine six and
19 months each of them are driven in a
completely different way one of them is
driven by incentives if you do this you
get XYZ the other one could care less
about the incentives but he's driven by
if you do this if you don't do this
you're gonna have these things taken
away from you oh that drives him he's
not driven by that right the other one
is very different with relationships
each of them are different here's the
issue in life
if you're a parent then you have kids
psychological torture for you to learn
how to move your kids no but here's a
problem most of us spend so much time
trying to figure out how to drive and
move other people in our lives but we
don't have any clue on how to drive
ourselves I created a quiz for you to
take so you learn exactly what drives
you if you want to find out what that is
for you click on the link above or below
go take the quiz you'll be surprised two
minutes later on what drives you